[MUSIC]
In 1990, my mom was having a big year.
She was going up for a huge promotion,
SVP at Morgan Stanley.
At the same time, she was going through
a more anxiety inducing process.
She was trying to get pregnant.
Now, my mom was the only woman in her
product group and she was a go getter.
She was also 31 and my parents were
having some trouble conceiving.
This meant that my mom wasn't
just trying to get pregnant,
she was going through IVF.
Her 12 hour work day now featured secret
trips to a broom closet where she
had to inject a large
needle full of hormones.
While her male colleagues
went to client happy hours,
she made up excuses and snuck off or
weekly trips to the doctor.
My mom covered her tracks because she
wasn't sure what her male colleagues would
think if they found out she
was trying to have a baby.
As she hid in that closet she wondered,
what her boss thinks she was
less committed to her job?
Would should be passed over when
they staff important deals.
Ultimately, my mom got that promotion.
But along the way, she miscarried.
Now, my mom didn't share any
of this with her coworkers.
And it turns out it's probably
good that she didn't.
Research on bias against pregnant
employees is far ranging and
scarily conclusive.
Pregnancy bias is real.
The workforce is 47% women, and more and
more of those women are delaying
childbirth to be a part of that workforce.
But the workplace isn't
changing to meet that reality.
Women are still trapped in their
own metaphorical broom closets.
It's time to stop the secrecy and
open up a dialogue.
So how can employers help reduce stigma
around pregnancy and fertility at work and
improve outcomes for all women,
all parents in the process?
Before we answer that, first we have
to ask, what is pregnancy bias?
To do that,
we're going to do a little experiment.
Raise your hands if you
plan on having children.
Way more than I practiced
having it's the answer.
All right, so raise your hands again
if you plan on working while you or
your partner is pregnant.
Same answer, great.
Now, raise your hands again,
if you're going to tell your employer
immediately about your pregnancy.
Nobody.
Cool.
All right.
So men in the room,
you should tell everybody.
Research shows us that once you're
a parent you'll be paid more,
hired more frequently.
Can be seen as more responsible.
But women, for us the story is different.
For us, parenthood is a penalty.
Controlling for hours worked, experience,
industry and education, pregnant women and
new mothers will be hired less,
paid less and seen as less competent.
The New York Times found
startling evidence of this,
even relative to their own
evaluations pre-pregnancy.
Once pregnant, women were
immediately seen as less committed.
They were left out of important meetings
and not given the same bonuses.
And y'all,
this problem is only getting worse.
The Equal Opportunity employment
commission found that this has been rising
for over 20 years when they studied
Pregnancy Discrimination claims.
And it's actually at
its highest point ever.
This could be partially caused by
our changing fertility landscape.
The average age of first childbirth is
also at its highest ever, especially for
women with undergraduate or
graduate degrees.
Take us again, as an example.
The women in this room, will likely
have their first child at age 33.
But, this trend of later stage
parenthood means that for
us having a baby might not be as simple.
Some of us, like my mom,
will need fertility assistance.
And treatments like IVF are time and
emotion intensive.
They can impact the work day and compound
our fears of being seen as less committed.
And though male factor infertility is the
root cause of nearly half of infertility
cases for couples, the treatments fall
squarely on the shoulders of women.
Now you understand the dynamics in play.
The reasons my mom hid in that closet.
Women are caught in this terrible tension
between pursuing their goals of motherhood
and being seen as less invested to
the careers they spent years building.
And pregnancy bias isn't just bad for
women.
It's bad for families and employers too.
So if you've been chilling
because you don't have a uterus,
it's time to check back in.
You need to build this
bias into your budget.
If you plan on having a dual
income household with children,
your female partner will statistically
never recover her earning power.
She will make on average $16,000 less
a year after having her first child.
That's a loss of over a million dollars
by the time you're both ready to retire.
And as future employers,
we need to prepare for
the attrition of valuable
employees from the workforce.
Given the penalty of motherhood and
the rising cost of childcare many women
debate the economics of returning to work.
So it's clear what we must do,
reduce pregnancy bias and
reduce the economic loss of talented
women leaving the workforce.
But hundreds of years of gender bias,
that is a lot to deal with all at once.
So let's start by tackling
the stigma around starting a family.
As base, we can look to for
inspiration is mental health to employers.
Employees dealing with mental health are
not dissimilar from women trying to get
pregnant.
In both cases, people are dealing
with highly emotional considerations.
Maybe juggling doctor's appointments and
may fear the judgment of their coworkers.
Many companies have successfully
implemented policies to reduce stigma
around mental health.
And specifically,
there are three that we can adopt.
First, let's dedicate HR resources
to pregnancy and fertility.
Let's sponsor educational programs that
clearly lay out fertility policy and
family leave.
Putting our voices strongly behind these
programs demonstrates commitment to
employees trying to become parents.
And it creates a culture of support,
not stigma.
Second, let's dedicate physical spaces on
site for women dealing with fertility.
There's no reason that someone going
through IVF should be injecting hormones
in a closet.
Creating spaces for this,
the same way we do for diabetics,
injecting insulin, helps dispel
the sense of shame and secrecy.
And it also minimizes
interruption to the work day.
It's a win win.
Third and finally,
we need to share stories.
Not just from women but from everyone,
particular from senior leadership.
Deloitte hosted a series of fireside
chats with partners who were dealing with
mental health at work.
And the results were immediate.
Employees immediately said that they felt
reduced feelings of stigma and isolation.
Talking about pregnancy and fertility the
same way not only serves to educate those
who may not be aware of the impact, but
it makes us more empathetic colleagues.
So sharing stories is
exactly why I'm here today.
Though the first round didn't go
quite as planned, my brother and
I were the successful results
of IVF cycle number two.
So I'm here, but
unfortunately my mom isn't.
We lost her to a battle with cancer
18 years ago, and that's why I'm
on stage in front of you right now, to
would have wanted me to share her story.
To keep another woman from
fighting these battles alone.
So here's my final ask.
Let's be better future employers.
Let's think about pregnancy bias
when we design our workspaces or
allocate our HR resources.
Let's think about pregnancy bias when we
hire, when we staff, when we promote.
Let's share our stories, all of us.
Let's be more empathetic employers
of not only women, but all parents.
You've listened to me,
now go out and listen to them.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]